you know like being a thought leader is
crippling to people because they think
they have to be a leader I think it's
being a thought contributor right so the
reason I hate when people like oh you
have to be a thought leader I'm like no
you don't you have to be a thought
contributor now at its worst is what we
say on social media every day which is
people pontificate as keyboard warriors
about [ __ ] they don't know at best I
think it's all of us being very
self-aware and deploying what we know
this portion is like with me so I think
this is one you need to get selfish like
you ask your question
hiring is guessing firing is known like
you gotta go fast that's how you get
[ __ ] done that's a bigger step out this
is the television and the television is
the radio before these [ __ ] my
first question is how do I gain the
trust with ad agencies or anything if
I'm not actually producing the content
and more so like the project manager by
reverse engineering what they value so
you may not be able to for some shops
for other shops just getting the volume
of output at a cost that allows them to
make margin is what they care about I
think one of them yes so I think what
you need to do is make sure this will
play for several people in the room I
think one of the biggest mistakes that
companies make in agency landscape and
SAS products is wasting time on selling
to the unsellable I'm just fascinated by
people's ideology that they want this
customer as if that customer is any more
valuable than the other person that pays
$6.99 a month because they made it
emotional to me the best way to sell
something is to be unemotional and go
fast and so there will be many people
that don't want to do business with you
because of that and there will be many
people that don't give a [ __ ] what you
need to do is spend as little time
trying to convince and as much time as
you can finding the ones that are lying
yep makes sense I'll let you sneak one
more in because it was quick and then
we'll get the third if we're gonna try
to go around it many times so we can
just now starting out how do you
approach people trying to share your
post or leave a comment you know and
that type of thing like
do you approach friends and friends
shared or is it you're trying to get
your target oh yes you know I think
there's a lot of different points of
view and you know obviously there's a
platform being built just down the table
to like help scale but you know to me
the thing that we'll spend time on when
I get to her is like I I don't think all
posts are created equal and so to me you
have to be agenda driven so for me I
think it's more about you joining
Facebook groups you creating LinkedIn
creative which i think will work for a
lot of you and then target with ad spend
against agencies and you replying
thoughtfully you know you shouldn't map
every single CEO that is a creative shop
that you want to do business with follow
her him on every platform and then
thoughtfully leave a comment of two to
three sentences to every post I
genuinely believe depth wins the social
game not with and I think everyone's
buying into width so for me I think
that's how you do it okay I think you
create your best thoughts and put them
out and I think you community manage a K
leave creative comments on things that
you think resonate in your world okay I
apologize real quick I'll give you an
example just leaving some thoughtful
point of view on photography under the
creative lead of a 15-percent agency in
Dallas leads to business development for
you because she sees that and she's like
who's this woman you know but where
everybody [ __ ] up in my opinion is
they go for scale not depth so like I
see a lot of people buying automation
tools to like people's posts just
because they think that gets them
awareness like a lot of short tactics
that are good for vanity metrics for
five minutes but terrible for business
we run into the art industry as people
are pretty cagey what they're using a
certain product or you know they want to
keep everything close to the vest but we
found referrals word-of-mouth and people
asking who are other users who are to be
the fastest sales okay
so I would turn that into creative and
pumped a living [ __ ] out of that on
LinkedIn oh you know what's that yep
audio yep video yep you know like I
think you know one of the things so for
example I think and this is really a fun
time to say it cuz it's two posts ago or
three now if you look at my Instagram
there's a cartoon right now my cartoon
said or comics or whatever you want to
call them have done quite well
ironically the one that's supposed to
repost ago is one of my least performing
posts in a long long time which is
perfect because it lets me make my point
the answer is yes to everything which is
why no matter what you were gonna say I
was and say yes and I was gonna do what
I just did because the reality is is
that people consume content differently
and so like the reason the number one
goal you have is to eliminate friction
for the person you're trying to sell to
at scale LinkedIn which is something I
didn't talk about at all until like 18
months of 12 months ago the reason it's
coming so much out of my mouth right now
is it's the first platform since
Facebook that has so much organic scale
like you're you have no brand you've
done nothing and you can literally write
an article about why you think Boca is a
good market to invest in why why you're
somebody good to invest in why the Boca
school my recommendation think like a
publisher not like a self selfish
salesperson why the Boca school system
is up-and-coming because you know
whatever it may be that posts for you
with no presence on LinkedIn is gonna be
seen by way more people than you can
ever imagine there is no platform right
now that gives free organic reach with
no paid support even remotely close to
face to LinkedIn and even the fact that
I almost just said Facebook was really
interesting to me
an insight because it was the only other
place and walked like it used to be
search on Google like if this was a
meeting in 1999 I would be yelling at
all of you be like okay so is this new
thing called SEO and you have to figure
out how to be number one on it
[ __ ] the yellow pages like you know it's
all been one game of that where can you
get the most awareness for the least
LinkedIn it's really uncomfortable now
for you
you're so specific that I would actually
spend the ad money to target people in
the art business and all of you can do
that the ads are a little more expensive
on LinkedIn but they're stunningly
targeted what I like is you've already
figured out what works some of us don't
know yet
now you turn those testimonials into
creative but find a way to make the
testimonial feel less like an
infomercial at night so you have to be
cool I'll give you a great example I I'm
gonna give you this one I think this
would kill get five of them
three of them in literally radical
candor email them be like hey we're
about to do something thing content but
instead of asking you to do a video for
me
testimonial I'd like to invite you and
four of my other high-quality clients to
dinner we're just I'm gonna buy you a
nice dinner we're gonna have some nice
bottles of wine and we're gonna talk
about the art industry as a whole and
I'm gonna film it and then do chop ups
and then put it on LinkedIn right then
as the you know hostess you'll talk
about macro but you'll find ways to
integrate things about your business
which inevitably will lead to some great
quote you know Johnny says [ __ ] yeah we
used to [ __ ] that up before you got it
so what I'm very good at and what
actually this is very meta
this right now is more for the content
than what you're paying our company to
be here just as this is not especially
running it through a veiner and all the
overhead not the best use of my time
financially it's I want the questions
and the content if you look at how much
of the contact by putting out last year
is from 40s this puts me in a good
position to create an
idea.the flub above linkedin and
facebook
dustin can now quote and that could be a
two million viewed because that's an
interesting piece of content right I
looked at him earlier when I said
something you I can't remember like the
depth with things you know so even like
literally the advice I'm giving you I'm
living in the meta right now create
environments this can lead to but like
this could lead to why you would do it
exhibit at your best friends gallery
about your product strictly about the
subject of the business of art but
you're filming it boom got it it's
really interesting if I want to get
everybody to think like a publisher I
need to make you think like art magazine
like real estate investment monthly
right like Vogue not like the company
you are because then you go from a
commercial to quality content that
actually easily people want and then if
I tell you where to put it that's under
priced that's the story of my life
that's who I am that's how I got here
bring value and figure out where it's
under priced so you get the maximum
amount of brand equity from this link
thing thing is a dream because it's a
business context world but it's acting
like Facebook and everybody's being
successful it's crazy I'm getting emails
it reminds me of early it definitely
will work so that's what I would do plus
then you're also doing retention you're
buying a nice standard for right you're
doing you're like you're winning on so
many fronts you know like people don't
do a good job with farming they do a
good job with hunting more customers
more customers but they don't do a good
enough job saying thank you to the ones
they got
so as I mentioned before my company is
basically and I'm trying to just you
know get my coat and the water so my
first question I guess is you know where
would you start you were me and this is
the concept of not wanting to be at the
mercy of brokers selling your properties
from a commercial standpoint yeah but
this is strictly on that side of it
right this is not to raise capital from
investors understood and you have you
have some inventory in Boca and Jersey
understood and so to me I think you're
barking up a really interesting tree and
it's something I think a lot about
because I think it's quite a lucrative
space because there's so much margin
being made by the brokers and there's no
innovation being done by the developers
I started giving you previews of it
couple things are based on that square
footage first you have the reverse
engineer who's likely to rent from you
so is this localized or is this at such
scale that we're looking for national
players
the one has got 20,000 square foot you
know
floor plans where I have like Geico and
big institutional where I still would
think it's local at least to Central
Jersey
shorty coat is tile playing field or
towns in the neighboring area but it's
pretty localized and then folk is the
opposite I have like 60 small offices
from 500 to you know maybe 3,000 max
four thousand nine there's two ways for
everybody to go here it's a good time to
put it into play we've gone down the
path of more of content as a publisher
you either want to become the magazine
or the guy or gal they put on the front
of the magazine right and and if you
think about it that's what I've done
both of right for my companies where the
magazine for me guarantee I'm the one on
the cover you know your reserve dude but
I never think that that's a prerequisite
to building a personal brand my biggest
fear is that I build I believe building
personal brand which I view is not
charlatan but more like having a
reputation in 1947 but I always worried
that if I'm the messenger of that advice
that people think that they should do it
the way I do it which is very hyperbola
my energy is pretty over-the-top that's
my natural energy when I'm on camera or
on stage but I think that um I think
that you have to make a decision of one
or the other or both and by the way that
goes for both of you as well you know
like being a thought leader is crippling
to people because they think they have
to be a leader I think it's being a
thought contributor right so the reason
I hate when people like oh you have to
be a thought leader I'm like no you
don't you have to be a thought
contributor now at its worst is what we
see on social media every day which is
people pontificate as keyboard warriors
about [ __ ] they don't know at best I
think it's all of us being very
self-aware and deploying what we know
right so you're a young is this is this
a business you start as a family
business this is what is this yes
started as a family business and
basically I just understood so like
that's was my intuition given the scale
or some other unusual reasoning that's a
huge advantage for you you get to write
and so you get to lean in and say look
this is this is you know like I think
that's an incredible thing to like like
lean into which is you have something I
had a 28 which is at 28 years old I know
everything about the wine and spirits
business because I've been doing it
since I was 14 and I was doing it
passionately and I gave up school and
social life to be the best at it and so
by the time I was 28 I was [ __ ] by
time I was 28 I was done actually I'd
achieved what I set out to do at 22 I
built one of the largest independent
stores I built a big business for my dad
and I was ready to kind of actually
start transitioning and disobey us
that's why Wine Library TV and all this
other stuff started happening which led
to the Gary Vee that we know today and
so I I think that's an incredible place
for you to play you know you can but you
have to be self-aware and you don't have
to build a personal brand if we're gonna
build it through the company's name cuz
you're more comfortable with that then I
think you need to produce a show or
content either a running podcast which
again doesn't even have to be you
preferably you because when you lose the
star that's a problem I think it's a has
so I'm a very big so Boca I'm very
interested in I'll tell you why I think
if you started a podcast called the Boca
small business forum you would crush
used this is something might eat
everybody I know Nick and I know you
guys have heard this multiple times the
high school party concept which is if
you host it you have the leverage so it
was always fasting and showed a bow or
big shout out Alan did it in my high
school took advantage of his pants and
parents not being around through the
parties went from a c-plus he was be
biased when he first came but one right
to an a popularity cuz he hosted the
party again whether it's you or some
other way you do it if you have the Boca
business podcast and you now are
inviting other businesses like like the
queen bee that's been there for 54 years
is the Baker or the real estate agent or
whoever right the guy who's got the
sailing
company like you host a party within a
five six months you have the podcast at
every SMB in bocas listening to aspiring
to be on but what it really becomes as a
gateway drug to you leasing out your
space you don't have to mention it once
and you'll lease it out you don't have
to mention it once they're just gonna
like who is that kid oh he owns a lot
you know like it's so I always tell
people let your profile do your selling
put out a lot of value in your content
if people like it they're gonna click
your URL in your Instagram let your
profile do your selling so I think those
are the themes that I'm thinking I love
the idea you guys haven't done the
personal brand part yet the pot like the
concentrate so like I will push
everybody to podcasts like you would not
believe even more than video because I
think video is a bigger mental and
infrastructural jump for many I love
podcasts because of the following you do
a podcast you film the podcast which
gives you video you get the guests
audience when they're a guest because
they're gonna promote it bringing you
awareness
I'm obsessed interview that's the best
part
I'm good at what I do and do something
almost note if you look at the top 100
podcasts outside of like shows that are
scripted like serial the amount of
individual humans who have a podcast
where they don't interview somebody in
the top 500 is almost non-existent it's
like me and I don't haven't done enough
homework but like maybe just not a lot
I'm trying to think who does a
straight-talking
know other guests I don't know
nonetheless podcasts are [ __ ] lay up
especially if you go my route and level
up and make it broader the Boca business
podcast the first person can be the
[ __ ] third generational guy who's 58
who owns the boat company in town that's
been crushing for years and when you
email him on LinkedIn or his email and
say hey John do you want to be the first
guest on the Boca business podcast
answers yes because John's not being
by anybody to be on a podcast got it and
then literally the contents of piece of
cakes so John tell us about how you got
started
so John what's happening now how's bokeh
changed in the last like you're [ __ ]
40 minutes done before you even started
asking for questions and going to sleep
yep
[ __ ] to be frank depending on your
ambitions and skill set make it Florida
I'll push you to America I just need to
know what your ambitions and
capabilities are does that make sense
I love Sioux hyperlocal because I think
it creates depth of results in a very
narrow place but I love national if
you've got the [ __ ] juice go you know
then you put the podcast on all the
platforms which is very easy you can
google it or we can tell you that's just
like record upload Spotify SoundCloud
you know iTunes
you know stitcher but then if you record
it and let's get it straight here for
the first eight years of my career I
didn't have a team so the way I would
have done it is like that like I would
have to have my iPhone on the table and
recorded it and then literally posted
the raw [ __ ] video on LinkedIn so
like you know people again being the
messenger a lot of these a lot of these
things right now scares me because I
have a level of notoriety now leveraged
infrastructure but I got here by doing
what I'm telling you to do amazing
that's crazy
that in you yeah that's good I mean look
that's as you know like to me I hope
people don't shy away from that you
should triple down on that it's the top
of the funnel good sure good good
is great like my team calls me no one is
they do a video of the day that in
addition to other mostly exclusively
some type sales where it's just me
holding my phone and I say it's a club
and I share whatever yeah today it was a
vaynermedia and getting people like that
access to that's where the theater if
the mind comes into me of course I've
been in a million green rooms so I like
that I've learned with my I ins like
that as well so we use that video to
give people that behind-the-scenes look
of like what it's like it's you know
female entrepreneurship of course of
course
which is great so we sometimes put it on
Instagram once no I don't like secrets
or on Twitter but I'm thinking about
LinkedIn of course you have to put it
everywhere you know that right well you
have to put it everywhere couldn't
actually post produced for everywhere
you're know yeah that to me is like cool
first of all let me give you great
advice any investor that will want to
invest in you because it's not
investment friendly it's not somebody
you would have won with anyway it's not
your DNA it's like me thinking about
that [ __ ]
got it you want to hear something even
better it's gonna help you what its
gonna actually do is keep those
investors away which is gonna save you
three to eight [ __ ] meetings that
are going to cost you time in the future
it's probably gonna make the investor
that you actually want come to you
instead of you going to her him you
understand this this is a big game of
wanting knows and that's where
everyone's getting confused think about
what I'm doing I'm super not friendly to
a lot of things to Patriot fans don't
want to work with me you know people
that don't like cursing you know so it
really will help you
you're welcome so first question so the
construction industry's rather behind on
when it comes to technology that's your
advantage yeah so so how do we sell to
companies it's similar to what I gave
party companies the related scans you
know
well those companies you know because I
know with related they're super
sophisticated so they're not behind you
know they'll be like to me the biggest
companies will judge you on merit like
what's what are they using alternatively
whether there's a direct competitor or
not dude is there a legacy tech
competitor which everybody deals with
like we did with resi with opentable
right we just had a really big exit to
American Express big win you know for us
we had to deal with open table there was
a legacy and that was bad
restaurants were further along had
infrastructure but we innovated made a
better product other things buddy media
right that's your world like you know an
investment that I did well with not even
if I gave a quote to and got a lot of
shares and did extremely well
Mike Lazaro one because it was first but
he got a lot of knows like Vayner Vayner
got an ungodly amount of noes 2009 to
2014
just cuz people didn't even believe in
social now they believe in it but they
try to look at it and they look at it in
different ways and our nose come from
the way they look at it not don't
believe in it at all related and others
are sophisticated enough to know if
there is technology is an excel sheet
and a piece of paper better than paying
you or are you perfect I think the long
tail is where it gets a little bit more
interesting where there is pushback
because a lot of let me know like a lot
of the people that are in the fields are
old school and they like to do things
the old school way and you know they
don't even if the technology is good
they're just stubborn and don't want to
use it it's the story of human beings
every industry has that my dad didn't
take credit cards or have a computerized
register when I first started you know
right you have their patience for the 28
year olds to take control or you need to
be smart and not bang your head against
the steel pillar to the people that
won't say no and find the five what you
would I be looking for I would do
homework on this if I was your partner I
was like okay sales plan hey you know
cuz I've come in and I don't know
anything I'd be like hey can we get
somebody to get a list of every family
family-centric you know organization
that already now has the daughter or son
that's under 40 in the business give me
that list I'm like okay then right then
I would look at that list and look okay
in order of size or close to us like
alright let's go the little martinis
because Sarah martini is now in the
business she's 29
we've done the Intel she's worked there
she left she went to business school she
came back to the family biz she's there
she inevitably is gonna be more open to
this conversation at the end I met when
daughters the other day good company
yeah I was awesome old school deed and
3.9 [ __ ] yeah I was like literally my
first piece of Isis I was like you need
a show on Bravo [ __ ] the construction
company I would meet no yes but I would
make jokes I have found a lot of success
in areas that are more like what I come
I come from the liquor business I come
from the construction business we just
didn't build things we sold liquor it
was that and I think one of the fun
things about
those real old-school businesses is
jokes like I would probably I'd never
give this advice but I'm giving it to
you I'd probably get some you know NYU
actors and actresses and literally
reenact scenes from the field that are
just cliche that could go viral within
the community it's funny I got really
upset the other day at the airport
because somebody was being really rude
to an airline employee and just you know
sometimes things click and I made this
video super narrow I'd go pretty general
with my content these days but it was
like airline employee stuff so we posted
it we did whatever did fine I think
pretty solid actually for narrow we ran
some ads against employees of that world
because I can tell you right now I were
an through LAX yesterday and [ __ ] was
like put on like I I think I could like
it was unbelievable like 20 different
airline employees like thank you so much
they like penetrated the subculture so I
think could have your one funny video
away from cliche we could all of us are
picturing the guys in the video now
doing some dumb [ __ ] on a piece of paper
the wind comes along and takes the pic
like just literally reenact or do it in
cartoon form
I think it would work Facebook will work
for you because that communities on that
platform because I was thinking about me
possibly putting out like some nostalgic
type content I actually think the
old-timers I think the old-timers your
problem yeah I think you're making
content for 28 year old Sally and for
the decision makers in comedic form and
information form save money same time
they know that that 32 year old CFO and
now all these companies or accountant
you know they know they just don't have
the leverage to make the move you need
to but they're but they make the call
like ultimately in these cliche examples
you know junior sons makes the call
you're not gonna win
[ __ ] sixty three-year-old Sal ever
[ __ ] you computer that's all [ __ ]
you see these hands right you know you
know I'm telling you right now it's
advice I've been giving for the last
couple of years
I get more emails about don't sell to
the unsellable and how it changed a
business that was doing 2 million a year
for 14 [ __ ] years and now they're
doing five cuz they stopped beating
their [ __ ] head against things that
aren't gonna happen it's friction
especially when it goes that old-school
because we're now into what I call
religion it's an emotional decision they
don't understand it they got four more
years into retirement and I'm not gonna
[ __ ] deal with that bullsh I don't
[ __ ] use I barely know how to use my
phone get out of here you're gonna
[ __ ] make me use this [ __ ] by the
time I figured out how to use it I'll be
slow right you say it's gonna save me
time no it's not I don't [ __ ]
understand to use this [ __ ] I can give
you at all because I live it I see it
yeah because it's just a kid yeah and an
ADA 10 times they don't even listen to
the smart kid back to beating your head
once I found out Sara's in the business
you go and have that meeting and you
figure out real quick that sara has no
say you're out and sara has no say eight
of ten times so like you're dealing with
a very small window the biggest boys and
girls and then family dynamics where you
get lucky two out of ten times that's it
that's your business which is great if
you actually know that and focus on that
you can build a real business Facebook
will really work for the community you
might want to start a Facebook group of
construction companies I'm very hot on
Facebook groups that's what Facebook
proper is becoming so starting a group
and maybe again notice where I'm about
to go similar to what I gave you
make it the Northeast construction
consortium that's the name of it here's
where we talk about modernizing our
industry see where I'm going all of a
sudden you're like on a non-profit not
your own business and then if you don't
spam them with like oh the only reason
why I mean this group is to pitch your
[ __ ] they're gonna find I'm telling you
right now they would bring value they
will find you so don't don't
[Music]
guys she use this app because it's a fun
time therefore saving them time on
projects right but I would rather them
do that not be the one that's you know
so then he gets the people the projects
the real estate people the developers
are the incentives that hey save you
time force your construction guys to use
it
you can definitely sell through that
channel you're welcome so I'm thinking
about creating content both there's no
common thread between Republicans and
Democrats right now and that's what you
have in a two-way my drivers of uber and
uber drivers don't have a common so you
know and so sorry please from the
business side someone who's like an
enterprise account like an arrow mark or
a Sodexo Persa caterer have really
different needs
yes I'll you props resonate really
different curriculum so if we have you
know like ten of them is it creating
different content for each yes yes from
everything from long-form through s and
we target the ads and inevitably where
some things over resonate so for example
your Instagram strategy is gonna
resonate much more with the caterers
because they themselves are trying to
market on that platform whereas the only
place you can get earmark is on LinkedIn
or if you decide to go the route of
building the food services number one
internal b2b podcast and again this is
why this is such a homerun you you start
the food services podcast literally and
you email the innermark CMO and she's
saying yes it's crazy
I can't I'm gonna say that's why I like
the high school party analogy because
inevitably two out of every three people
went to a high school where somebody who
wasn't the most popular kid junior year
became the person that hosted the party
and became a lot more popular it's just
something you can understand like oh my
god that's right Ricky did that and
that's the same thing as like you can't
get in the door at the number five that
some of these conglomerates but then you
email cold on LinkedIn the number one
CEO and their press person or comms
person's like oh yeah we want him on
podcasts and then when it's a literal
Florida you know that's what I mean we
have a podcast show on the gallery media
group called the CMO podcast just so
CMOS keep running through our doors so
I'm eating the food I'm putting down you
mean in the individual cohorts that
group but that's different then yeah do
not mix them it won't work
it there is if you look at the dynamics
of groups or forums or communities like
it needs to be specific it's why so many
people are confused by what they don't
understand what I do with my content
where I do garage saleing and wine and
entrepreneurship they think that that's
contradictory to the by some giving has
a human it's your strength as a company
it's your weakness cool high school
party cool like let's go to court a
softball game or something locally well
we don't have the manpower Bulova we try
ecommerce and it was great for data on
like where in the country people like
the cookies but shipping was a problem
because the cookies kept breaking we get
accounts and they're growing nationally
slowing penetration in New England and
Northeast so how do we use social media
aside from being hyper local which is a
given in New England but like just to
get interest for other people elsewhere
so they can ask their stories so sonic
restaurants here the which is a client
ironically a Boehner but even if they
weren't this would rob I don't know if
you know this but for years they were
only in the southeast but they would run
commercials in North East and so this is
device I'm giving you I've always
thought that the sonic move on the on
the queue SR level
was always the smartest b2b distributor
and reselling move like you could build
up so much demand on Facebook LinkedIn
and Instagram in Arizona by making to
prove my point I would make a
Diamondbacks cookie make it up and then
only market it in Arizona to Diamondback
fans and just literally show Europe if I
was the other son be like watch this and
in a hundred days inbound enquiries to
carry it manifest through execution
that's why so I I said something about
the secret the other day like [ __ ] the
secret you know that book like you you
know and people got really mad that I
carry manifestation is real like because
you did something behind it like I also
have a goal it's called buying than you
know are you gonna say that buying the
New York Jets was a manifestation no I
yes I said it
but it was cuz I was doing things yes oh
yes manifesting through very tactical
you know you could even target actual
retailers you guys could thoughtfully
sit down and say okay in Minnesota
there's this great family gourmet chain
of 11 locations like if I was a wine
producer just to give a comp I would try
to get two copies or Martinelli's in
mass I tried to get two Haskell's in
Minnesota like you could get real
thoughtful I mean you can get so crazy
when you actually make the car but the
the cookie Martinelli's and capys are
two big chains and mass for liquor you
can literally create a cookie called the
cat market the [ __ ] out of it and then
just target ads to employees of cappy's
and inevitably they're gonna like holy
[ __ ] there's a [ __ ] cookie called the
cap we have to carry that I mean it's
it's so scary what I know I can do
anything with this model what do you
want to happen
it's just reverse engineering of course
you have to you have to understand you
know his is real easy right because
you're dealing with cookie that inept
that and you're talking about an
environment where the stores ROI is
predicated on bringing in new items
kicking out items things of that nature
where his poor him getting into stores
where I just showed you I could do crazy
uncomfortably the game that we'd have to
play is retention the game where I'd
have to really help him is retention
because if I looked under the hood his
economics might not even be that
attractive and opening an account that
then kicks out the product after ninety
days now the good news is back to that I
think I could get him twelve and cuz
then I lose sex and like that's what I
would do I'd like right we need in order
what a twelve [ __ ] you know like mom
and pops or one-offs or six store units
or did it software's tougher but far
more lucrative that's why they're big
businesses you you know you've got to
get it once you get in it's hard to get
out of bad even bad software it takes
two three years which is why we all love
building SAS businesses getting in is
tougher but what you could do is
actually reverse engineer every single
business and decision maker you could
actually spend I think people are so
worried about talking then they're
spending no time and listening your
ability to cry mean her ability to
literally create all fifty agencies that
are within driving distance of her home
because that's just smart like why get
an account that's far away and then
literally just stalk a K do homework on
the pain points and words out of the
mouth of like I mean she could possibly
and you know this especially being an
extra burn like her business may come
from the fact that they're both maverick
fans she could make a luca donna CH
reference in a post I mean that works on
me you know so you know what
you you know make me you know the thing
the thing there is that's your business
where's like its ask you under his world
so it gets a little trickier but I think
the thesis of reverse engineering your
target is again I don't think I don't
think it's not maybe Nick you might have
caught this there was this great moment
four or five years ago my team me
staying out here which I do once or
twice every couple months where I
basically declared I was gonna get
popular and hip-hop and everybody made
fun of me made fun of me and then I just
did it right in her face you can do it
if you've got if your products good then
you can do anything you just have to
understand how the internet works so
that's what I would do in that scenario
I'd also really really really challenge
you to innovate on shipping you know I
think one of the things that I've
noticed with a lot of food products is
that they were half pregnant with their
execution on e-comm and it's so
imperative for the growth of their
business long term that putting some
money and more importantly heart and
head behind actually trying to solve it
instead of being like it's and I family
businesses love to do this yes they do
and I think that that is super important
because much like brokers retailers take
way too much of the action you don't
want them to have control and you don't
want somebody to come along scary scary
let's keep it going
let's go free for him raise your hand
good
with the other generated content we
believe that humans and AI should work
in partnership because as you know
marketing is emotions and I couldn't
agree more and do you guys tell them
that that is the best practice yes good
watch we don't even we we believe in it
so much we don't wanna make anything
even though we think that that's
inefficient and should but I've been so
passionate to build the religion of
context not automated scale that if I
did it now now the company would be
thoughtful about it if I did it first
it'd be like everybody else in the world
and 99% of your clients and we just met
with Facebook 99% of what celebrities do
like everybody wants automation nobody
actually wants to build a meaningful
relationship they just want the likes
and the sales come aware go ahead
phenomenal and I'm sure like we we hack
with stuff but like the fact that like I
don't even know that is well you can lay
our services on top of it I think you
should tell the world that it would be
far more effective for them to pay an
extra five thousand dollars a month for
post-production before they post than
just hitting the post Sanat who's who on
our team is using this product I wanna
get the insight cool
let's find ragab I want to just hear him
talk for a second you know I think I
think I think you would be stunned if
you went with this approach and I
understand why you wouldn't hey I know
let me go let me give you the pitch hey
we would how much is your product
understood so give me the range
a month or 10,000 a month cool
it's 50 to 10,000 right cool hey you can
use this at 100 bucks a month and we're
very proud of the product if you pay an
extra thousand a month that hundred a
month actually works like two thousand
instead of the hundred working like 30
hi Jen ually believe that to be true
how are using this tool understood and
how'd you find it do you know the story
what was it awesome thank you I'm sure
awesome thank you I
I think I think I think that I think
that I think you just roll with that I
think you roll it I think you make that
part of the sales pitch if nothing at
first of all yeah yeah hey super excited
you're checking us out
so look based on the way you look like
you're gonna do it I think you're gonna
be 300 bucks a month just FYI we have a
creative services overlay which does the
post-production that is actually the
variable of success our tool gets you to
third and a half base but the human
creative variable from third an app base
to home plate is so much more
significant now this may sound weird
even though you're only paying 250 a
month our service for our creatives and
our strategist and our copywriters is a
thousand a month in addition we're
thrilled to have you at 250 and we think
there's nothing that competes for 250 in
the market however just on the record
whether you do it and we don't do it for
a thousand or you pay us to do it for a
thousand at 12:50 intuitively I feel
like you're getting $2,500 worth of
value verse excuse me I have 1000 you're
getting $2,500 worth of value or excuse
me at 1250 I had to rate the person
you're getting 2500 dollars of value at
250 bucks we think you're getting $350
worth of value so if you can afford it
you can imagine how that amortizes or
you still pay us 250 but you better
[ __ ] hire somebody and pay them
40,000 a year to post produce everything
cuz you can't imagine the Delta here's
three [ __ ] versions of me doing it by
hand
that's the pitch yep that's the pitch
you got it it will work here's why 25
percent will hire you for it and you'll
start building a vaynermedia on top of
it it won't be as efficient as a SAS
business but it'll bring up your you
know ROI and like they'll be you know
it's gonna work better it's gonna help
your LTV 20 percent twenty percent are
gonna do it internally in a way they
wouldn't have done it if you sold it
differently they'll do it right which is
40% more than um now
and again back to the specific industry
it's still very like a high-touch oval
ah yes it's a meeting and handshakes and
I'm like how can we break into it and
layer in more digital content to
alleviate some of our sales reps from
having to have so many face-to-face I
think that won't unless you get people
to communicate via text or or screen
times or things you won't eliminate it I
think what content will do is make your
funnel much bigger so now you're now
you're talking more about the DNA of the
sales team it goes back to the
construction guys it's getting them to
push for more you know scalable
communication some of them are most
naturally comfortable in face-to-face
there's many salespeople who
subconsciously subconsciously think
going to meetings is what there is
justifying their being yeah so funny a
lot of my like because clients are like
Gary you know you know my teeth I get it
but my team doesn't you believe in this
and I'm like change the kpi's if you
believe in it and you're the CEO Sally
make the bonuses predicated on your
marketing people spend 25% of Facebook I
have a funny feeling if their personal
bonus is tied to a requirement of
spending 25% of the money on Facebook
like it's unbelievable watching leaders
push the envelope on their employees to
your point which was I'm glad you picked
up on so quickly change the kpi's it's
so fun to like companies that bonus we
don't really do that here but like you
pull control can make people do whatever
[ __ ] you want
we have a couple of different things in
place for like the heads of the offices
and some of the Vayner I think the
Sascha group is taking a different
approach with James cuz he comes from
that ecosystem letting him do that with
these guys so like we're starting to
have some but like I vote bonuses scare
me as a macro because I I'm worried
about a disconnect I'm worried about you
know Nick and I even being on a
arbitrary bonus truck I mean some things
are black and white but even that scares
me because if you're if you're doing it
just completely on a financial KPI
people's behaviors become so erratic and
often don't map to the culture or the
gray or the long term that I'm trying to
build so it's inherently against it and
then the only other way to do it for me
is subjective but then you're then he's
walking and thinking he should get 22k
and bonus and I'm thinking 13 and that's
fine cuz that's not a super big apart
but literally I just had somebody and
this is a race cycle they're walking in
they think they deserve $100,000 reason
I think they deserve a $5,000 race and
that's real that literally just happened
and I'm like that's gonna be tricky like
I'll get back to you like you know like
hey I don't know what you know literally
went down like I got a lot of thinking
to do what's gonna happen here so you
know okay I get it
yeah I mean investors are excel sheet
Goldman Sachs you know business school
junkies they just think it's right and
it actually leads to incredibly bad
human behavior and if you competitive it
just leads to people have to live and
they have factored in the max of their
bonus first well people don't have to
say money like if you have an employee
who literally has an arbitrary bonus
between 15 and 50 thousand she's living
with the 50,000 in mind then it comes in
you give her 26 cuz he had a bad year
she was just okay she's like [ __ ] she's
like I my credit card bill is not
getting paid off like it's just crazy
people don't factor real into theory I I
always go here when I get in this
mindset I always implore people to read
mark ISM and communism on paper it
sounds remarkable every person that be
intermedia would love it it's extremely
socially liberal it just isn't
inherently human some things are better
on paper and business became one to
one-dimensional and finally I see some
of the tide turning starting to have EQ
and gray conversations but in the rise
of Finance and startup it was run by an
old boys club of you know Harvard
Business School told me that SIA just
not my thing on the investors yeah smart
it is the strategy III couldn't be more
bullish on that for somebody who's
raising capital always be putting out
content to raise capital so that when
you have to raise capital you're on
third base not [ __ ] the dugout
couldn't be super bullish on it
I actually think the other thing you
guys could be doing is already marketing
for the exit like here's why here's why
you know like just you it's never the
wrong time to take somebody grossly
overpaying like I I have always said
everybody this is never for sale and if
it's for sale quit but inherently
there's always a 1% chance in my head
I'm like well if Disney realizes this
creative machine and they offer me three
billion dollars tomorrow it's a wrap cuz
it's just too much it's just not there's
nothing I can like you know I would
trick Disney into thinking nobody's
gonna quit then ever would probably quit
cuz I've been telling him to quit but
I'd [ __ ] figure it out because it's a
too big of a number and it's just the
Million Dollar Man is right everybody's
got a price
so like marketing now for the exit is
also a good idea
um having a good understanding of who
might want to buy you and then making
content about you in a way that lends
them to start putting seeds to why they
should buy you running an article
writing running a piece of creative that
is titled why food service companies
should own all their internal tech and
then subconsciously like it's humans are
funny
they're real funny like the see you know
the CFO of a board all of a sudden goes
we should run it we should have our own
internal tech who do we use quick let's
buy them that's what happens how do you
go about marketing like I want basically
the buildings half-full so about 70,000
square centers yeah and you're and are
you trying to think about the notion of
how do you market to the other
businesses using Cosi is like a gateway
drug to them considering it
go you know vending machines that I took
out of there and you think it's a value
prop and might be and might be the
reason somebody considers to move look I
would pound and I mean pound the 20-mile
radius of your company or this location
on LinkedIn I would pound the living
[ __ ] out of it but one more time because
I want to give you good advice you steal
and they actually you ready now I
remember what you answered you still
believe it's basically a localized
transfer this is not somebody going from
Trenton to here it's not Bergen County
to there it's not oh hi oh - there it is
within that radius is what your
intuition is I would probably run to
cohorts of ads about the project on
LinkedIn against business owners within
a 15-mile radius and then a separate one
business owners in New Jersey to get the
same thing that his family cookie
business found out by having EECOM which
is like wait a minute
there's random demand in Denver I think
just running the ads might give you some
insight and and then please all of
Jersey and again you've got Nick and
others here Maribelle like they'll help
you kind of like club tie some of these
ribbons up that I'm putting down like
what did he mean by that or how do I
actually do that we can order on a
follow up call like we want to bring
value but that's what I would do
LinkedIn ads are expensive cuz there's a
floor starts at $2 CPMs instead of five
cents like Facebook or $0.10 like but
but it's very high-quality and organic
without paid will work but when you post
that hey this is one of the hey the
premier central Jersey you know office
space is here now with you know if even
maybe if you made it a commercial if you
post that organic on your if you made a
page for that building or even on your
organic linkedin that could meet that
could hit somebody in Florida the reason
you pay for the ads is you get to get
narrow I want you to do broad content
because it's just always a good idea it
could lead to a million different things
it could let me give an example it could
lead to a third generation family that
doesn't have a succession plan in a real
estate empire saying this kid seems
smart and he comes from a pedigree of
multi-generational
I'm gonna reach out to him and see if he
wants to operate my business since I
have nobody to give it to like I could
lead to that you do you see where I'm
going
that's why content done right always is
a good idea it leads the things you're
not even thinking about you saying
something thoughtful in a video that was
built to get people in Dallas area to
work with you may lead to somebody in
Oregon reaching out to you and saying
don't do that we thought that was
brilliant why don't you become the
back-end infrastructure for us and
you're like I did that I don't want to
do that and they're like but we'll do
this and you're like well that makes it
financially worth my time like like like
what I like about the content is it
creates you to be open to things you
might have not even thought of that's
the brilliance of a volume creative
model the reason I'm smart and have all
these insights is because I've created a
content machine that led to me listening
it looks like I'm talking it led to me
listening right it is crazy it's a good
one
I made sure Dustin caught it you know
all the talking has led to a level of
listening that gives me such profound
consumer insights
go doctor strategy wasting time on
annoying customers rfp's over yeah which
I like of course I love firing for my
customers
you know we're still well of course I'm
still young enough that every customer
kind of almost no no that's right so you
know there's a lot of theories about how
many call will mean touches or emails
whatever it is social touches that it
takes to get a customer right it's
twelve fourteen like so if I had these
leads and they're they're ball fight
would be qualified like taking that
metaphor or any consideration like
really how much time do I want my people
trying to reach somebody you're trying
to convince somebody oh we know that if
we give you a demo I have a 50% chance
of closing it telling you all the way an
18%
sorry I have an 80% chance of actually
closing you as a sale and 50% of go to
trial so demo was good I want to give in
the balance a like he meant I think but
right now I know that
because you're a sales organization
right now not a marketing one which is
okay it's the story of 99.9% of SAS
products it's just not what I think the
white side piece is I'm aware makes
sense yep and what you want to do is
create one anchor piece of creative that
is your show that becomes the catch-all
top to everything if everybody here
leaves with a podcast and that is really
where I'm going more than the blog then
I've won because I really think it will
work you know not everybody's gonna be
good at it but when you do very narrow
podcasts you only need a very small
group of people listening this is not
about making the askgaryvee show
you know you get seven people to listen
and to become customers for a lot of you
it's going to be our high positive
especially when you're amateur level and
have sales teams it becomes wildly
positive
like it's all I did we had that we had a
really famous piece of Ga'Hoole of
famous we had a piece of content we that
I limit phrase there was a piece of God
that we made that I liked that just
showed all the it was just all these
highlights of me being on different
podcasts and YouTube shows and it showed
how many views the video had 100 792 for
showing to people like lower lower
everyone's trying to get on Joe Rogan's
podcast he doesn't want you you know
like like you need you need you've got a
long way to go before you get there
let's get on the ones that you can and
more importantly let's host the one
you're far more likely to host and get
somebody way above your skis then you
are to get on somebody's show that's
bigger than you especially if you film
it and then post it and target against
you I I do more podcasts now than I used
to because I'm filming in its give me
content being on them is great too if
you record it even if you're in you're
off like I literally record that's a
little record me on a speakerphone doing
a podcast everything's about content
it's it's sometimes a good short-term
sales mechanism and always a brand is a
brand detriment address that publicly
truthfully including if I was wrong it's
the only move there is no other move no
yeah there is there is actually that's
absolutely absolutely true going into
hibernation and waiting for the news
cycle to end is an option but unlike
1949 for 2000 for that matter it lives
on the Internet in perpetuity and more
importantly here's the key of making a
mistake even if you're like on the
scummy side of a mistake America will
reward you for the I'm sorry and then
you can just move forward like you're
such a young kid without knowing
anything of why you're asking that
question without knowing anything just
going alt like this is crazy that I said
this the other day to somebody I believe
that saying I'm sorry is so revered in
our society that sometimes it's not a
joke
I think about making a doing something
on purpose that's bad to just say I'm
sorry because I think net-net it would
be better
to always say I'm sorry no matter what
happens the first thing that comes out
of everything on the mouth yeah yeah and
then to that point of like going from
smart tactic to deep intent is
everything you know like there was
something somebody made a mistake here
very senior with another employee who's
not here anymore got a little ugly
person said they were sorry in a nice
way and I was like okay and now in a
month I want you to do something that
makes them really know you're sorry so I
want you to watch everything they're
about and whether it's for their
daughter or for them or donation to a
charity or giving a thousand bucks to a
GoFundMe of their friend's house that
burned down now show them it really look
for somebody so good at scale pizzazz
sizzle all this it's about the steak
it's about the long-term it's about the
truth it really works so to answer your
question especially if you're going
through it's somewhat laying low is cool
because it allows you not to confront
and you get away with some short-term
ROI but it's always there saying you're
sorry and taking a little bit more of a
beating lets you go fast for the next 80
years
this will help you cope ability that's
like the ability to cope with it the
judgment yes yeah then you address that
truth even if you don't want to call
that person out by name if it's the
truth and it's not the excuse you came
up with for convenience for yourself
which many people do in that same
scenario if it's a hundred percent the
truth then you come out and you reply in
video form where there's no confusion in
written form and you post that truth if
it's seventy percent true and 30 percent
is the convenient of how one wants to
not take on accountability you need to
come out with the energy of 70 and 30
yeah it's it's really and then if it's
completely your I thought you'd go in a
different place I was hoping you were
but so say it anyway cuz it's super
interesting to me I've been thinking a
lot about this practice of losing and
saying you're sorry is an incredibly
powerful game we are in such a judgment
society right now a complete lack of
interest of accountability and a
complete interest in blaming others that
the people that practice I'm sorry and
accepting their losses are going to
become monstrous okay go ahead sneak it
in well no go ahead okay some work on
this brand but you can only physically
bite here I think the number one tactic
is community management on Twitter
searching 500 different key terms that
are indicators that they're gonna be
here because once they're here it's hard
you need to win them the day before got
it
quote uncle like literally 500 terms on
search locked in going to New York trip
to New York my vacation vacation you
know
that's really nice thank you thank you
you're welcome
thanks guys I'll see you guys later yes
yes
what am I going
you